[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois nous vous proposons une
semaine de cinéma à la française puisque
nous aurons quatre films en tous genres
français avec deux comédies le lion je
suis le dr tardy commencé par me dire
comment vous appelez et au milan nom de
code le livre les homes il en existe pas
si la couverture
c'était un bon beat ou quoi et l'esprit
de famille mini q la coop être au point
je sais que je tourne un thriller les
traducteurs et un film d'animation
samsam en sortie nationale à partir
trois ans pour les enfants
le thriller réalisé par régis roinsard
avec lambert wilson
les traducteurs nous raconte l'histoire
de neuf traducteur enfermé dans une
luxueuse demeure afin de traduire le
dernier tome d'un ce très célèbre roman
internationale mais lorsque les dix
premières pages du roman sont publiées
sur internet est un pirate menace de
dévoiler la suite si on ne lui reverse
pas une rançon colossal une question
devient obsédante ci est le coupable
un scénario palpitant qui vous fera
frémir d'inquiétude
ce thriller les traducteurs est fait
pour vous à retrouver nous donc à
l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]